what we're going to do in this video is
try to draw connections between angular
displacement and notions of arc length
or distance traveled so right over here
let's imagine I have some type of a
tennis ball or something and it is
tethered with a rope to some type of a
nail and so if you were to try to move
this tennis ball it would just rotate
around that nail and it would go along
this blue circular path and let's just
say for the sake of argument the radius
of this blue circle right over here
let's say it is six meters you could
view that as the length of the string
and we know what's going on here the our
initial angle theta initial the
convention is to measured relative to
the positive x axis our theta initial is
PI over 2 and let's say we were to then
rotate it by 2 pi radians positive 2 pi
radians so we would rotate in the
counterclockwise direction 2 pi and then
the ball would end up where it started
before so theta final would just be this
plus 2 pi so that would be 5 PI over 2
and of course we just said that we
rotated in the positive in the positive
counterclockwise direction we said we
did it by 2 pi radians so I kind of gave
you the answer of what the angular
displacement is the angular displacement
in this situation Delta theta is going
to be equal to 2 pi radians the next
question I'm going to ask you is what is
the distance that the ball would have
traveled and remember distance we
actually care about the path so the
distance traveled would be essentially
the circumference of this circle think
about what that is and actually while
you pause the video and think about what
the distance the ball traveled is also
think about what would be the
displacement that that ball travels well
the easier answer I'm assuming you've
had a go at is the displacement the ball
ends up where it started so the
displacement in this situation is 0
we're not talk about angular
displacement we just talk about regular
displacement would be zero the angular
displacement was 2 pi radians but what
about the distance and we'll denote the
distance by s as we can see as we'll see
we can also you view that as arclength
but here the arc is the entire circle
what is that going to be equal to well
we know from earlier geometry classes
that this is just going to be the
circumference of the circle which is
going to be equal to two pi times the
radius so it's going to be equal to 2 pi
times 6 meters times 6 meters which in
this case is going to be 12 pi and our
units in this case is going to be 12 pi
meters would be the distance that we've
traveled now what's interesting right
over here is at least for this
particular case to figure out the
distance traveled to figure out that arc
length it looks like what we did is we
took our we took our angular
displacement in fact we took the
magnitude of our angular displacement
you could just view this as the absolute
value of it
and we multiplied it times the radius of
our circle if you view that as the
length of that string is R we just
multiply that times R so we said our arc
length in this case was equal to the
magnitude of our change in displacement
times our radius let's see if that is
always true so in this situation I have
a ball and let's say this is a shorter
string let's say this string is only 3
meters and it's initial angle theta
initial is PI radians we see that as
measured from the positive x-axis and
let's say we were to rotate it clockwise
and so let's say our theta final is PI
over 2 radians so theta final is equal
to PI over 2 radians pause this video
and see if you can figure out the
angular displacement so the angular
displacement in this situation is going
to be equal to theta final which is PI
over 2 minus theta initial which is PI
which is going to be equal to negative
PI over 2 does this make sense yes
because we went clockwise clockwise
rotations by convention are going to be
negative so that makes sense we have a
clockwise rotation
pi over 2 radians now based on the
information we've just figured out see
if you can figure out the arc length or
the distance that these this tennis ball
at the end of the string actually
travels this tennis ball at the end of
the 3 meter string what is this distance
actually going to be well there's a
couple of ways that you could think
about it you could say hey look this is
1/4 of the circumference of the circle
so you could just say hey this arc
length s is just going to be 1/4 times 2
pi times 2 pi times the radius of 3
meters times 3 and this indeed would
give you the right answer this would be
what to 2 over 4 is 1/2 so you get 3 PI
over 2 and we're dealing with meters so
this would be 3 PI over 2 but let's see
if this is consistent with this formula
we just had over here is this the same
thing if we were to take the absolute
value of our displacement so let's do
that so if we were to take the absolute
value of our I should say our angular
displacement so we take the absolute
value of our angular displacement and we
were to multiply it by our radius well
our radius is 3 meters and these would
indeed be equal because this is just
going to be positive PI over 2 times 3
which is indeed 3 PI over 2 so it looks
like this formula is holding up pretty
well and it makes sense because what
you're really doing is you're saying
look you have you have your traditional
circumference of a circle and then
you're thinking about well what
proportion of the circle is this arc
length and so if you were to say well
the proportion is going to be the
magnitude of your angular displacement
this is the proportion of the
circumference of the circle that you're
going over if this was 2 pi you'd be the
entire circle if it's pi then you're
going half of the circle but notice
these two things cancel out and so this
would actually give you your arc length
let's do one more example so let's say
in this situation the string that is
heathering our ball is 5 meters long and
let's say our initial angle is PI over 6
radians right over here and let's say
that our final angle so is right we end
up right over there so our theta final
is equal to PI over 3 based on
everything we've just talked about what
is going to be the distance that the
ball travels what is going to be the arc
length well we could first figure out
our angular displacement so our angular
displacement is going to be equal to
theta final which is PI over 3 minus
theta initial which is PI over 6 which
is going to be equal to PI over 6 and
that makes sense this angle right over
here we just went through a positive PI
over 6 radians we went in the
counterclockwise direction and then we
just want to figure out the arc length
we just multiply that times the radius
so our arc length is going to be equal
to PI over 6 times our radius times 5
meters so this would get us to 5 PI over
6 meters PI over 6 meters and we are
done and once again no magic here it
comes straight out of the idea of the
circumference of a circle